oh man we're gonna watch today from HBO
what's this called John Paterna Aparna
japa Al Pacino is in this HBO movie we
have watching
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you should say I told you what did the
kids that happened I didn't tell good a
kid
so who talked to the kid she makes money
by telling lies she doesn't have a good
life she doesn't get a good paycheck you
need to resign before somebody does it
for you
[Music]
damn
whoa Jerry did Oh
[Music]
oh boy just change a few letters does
Pacino that's heavy man secretary story
this recent like this this feels like
modern yeah yeah the Jerry Sandusky
situation was in the last what ten years
at least but but more relevant now than
ever
well yeah I mean the this kind of story
the the doors have blown off this
portion of misbehavior in society and
and toxicity and stuff and yeah I
remember hearing all about the Sandusky
stuff not so much about Joe specifically
like I remember there was controversy
over Joe Paterno not coming out with
anything or coming forward sooner or
doing anything to stop this and what did
he know and what didn't you know yeah I
didn't really know the intimate details
of this that's that's an interesting
approach to take because as opposed to
taking it from the actual player and
focusing on him its focus on Paterno all
these institution with all these cases
coming out with all these stories coming
out oftentimes like the closest ones to
that person get questioned though
closest ones to them like did you know
how much did you know you're also
accountable to because you knew
something and you didn't do anything
about it and you still supported this
person all the time all the time now
especially so yeah this story's very
relevant right now well that line she
says at the end about you you must not
have known because you let it pull with
our kids and like that moment where you
just linger on his face is like I mean I
love Pacino in these HBO dramas like
I've seen anything I've seen you don't
know jack he's amazing in at Angels in
America he's amazing in that too I feel
like when it comes to the HBO movies
this guy really shows those shows not
when it comes to like those weird like
was the one that just came out the the
the one with freaking a dread guy Karl
Karl
oh I vaguely know yeah tell it's
probably just gonna be him all along he
just wants a paycheck I get a movies
like this like this is this is one
Pacino's the Pacino we know and love
yeah and yeah this looks like a powerful
performance really a really timely story
right now important one here too and a
fascinating perspective but in more than
just Pacino's storyline I mean that I I
don't know this actresses but the one
the journalist we would like the what
investigative reporter who's really
uncovering all this yeah I love a good
journalism story yeah I feel like
journalism stories are so fascinating
yeah it seems like a really cool
journalism story yeah definitely the
idea that you're taking a Paterno and
it's not like a Paterno biopic so much
as you're using him as a sort of
centerpiece of this whole situation that
you're probably gonna explore from all
sides
and even I got lying to of like we
should be focusing on the victims not
Paterno why is everyone so focused on
this right now yeah well if that's what
often happens to there's all that
sitting down the way ya see it now - and
you're the powerhouse like that when
you're Jo PAH you know it makes me
wonder if this script was like sitting
on the shelf for a while and then when
all this stuff started happening they're
like you know we should break our movie
yeah I feel like because everything
broke out I don't imagine they just
whipped up a strip that seeds like the
probably the kind of story that had a
strip sitting on the shelf for a while
then everything coming out there like
now's the time to make this yeah so in
some ways I'm like feels timely feels
important but there's also that side of
me that's like seems a little
manipulative capitalizing on something
right now movies that some might argue -
you know that's that's what movies are
supposed to do is represent the times it
all it all comes down to the execution
and this is a story that's been a few
years out yeah you know there's teller
they just made the Harvey Weinstein
movie you know yeah
yeah the dust hasn't settled at all it's
just on Ben Affleck clearly you just
wanted to jump on that firewall it's hot
you know no I don't get that vibe anyway
from this and I feel like HBO approaches
these things with a certain amount of
respect yeah man you spanner down
totally true to the real life issues
he's been well yeah we struggled
artificial intelligence it's coming the
futures here the futures here pretty
soon we're gonna have that issue
yeah well patina looks powerful in it
something I'm drawn to like a good eye
not know he was doing that I was in the
pool to patinas posture just gets worse
and worse as time goes on well yeah I
was watching this and wondering like is
he doing a good like just kind of yet
incredible he's always had bad posture
even back to the young Dog Day Afternoon
he's always that bad posture but now
that one showers on the football feeling
like oh man his posture is just like way
worse yeah a little frail I'm an old man
he's got that nose on that's one of his
that one of the few character things
he'll often do is great nose work from
Al Pacino all right guys well thanks for
tuning in you sisters Jenna and they're
cooking Odie
[Music]
you